we have a rule around here when we
recognize a recurring theme we take it
as a pattern last hour I had a gentleman
call in who was making $200,000 a year
that owed one hundred and ninety
thousand dollars on his student loans
and he wanted to do the Total Money
Makeover and get out of debt and he said
his wife wouldn't let him this hour we
had a gentleman call in that said he
bought a $10,000 car at 20% interest and
he wanted to negotiate the price but his
wife wouldn't let him that's two in a
row one H hour for the last two hours so
let me help you with this this is a
problem okay it's a problem married
couples that are smart and that are
mature and that have functional
relationships take input from each other
and one of them doesn't wear the pants
in the family we work together proverbs
31 says who can find a virtuous wife for
her worth is far above rubies the heart
of her husband safely trusts her and he
will have no lack of gain so I don't
make major decisions without my wife and
I being in agreement but I don't utter
the whistle five
wimpy words my wife won't let me either
come on guys man up a little here square
your shoulders and at least be half the
program ladies don't be married to a
wimp anyway not good ones now there's
some toxic overbearing you know out
there that are test pilots in a broom
Factory or something but you know that's
a different thing right but I'm talking
about real solid women that are Empire
changers and Empire makers they don't be
married to a wimp and by the way men
don't want to be married to you know
barefoot and pregnant and stupid you
know we want to be married to a woman
that has some square shoulders too and
has a brain and uses it and uses it to
raise great kids and you
is it in our in our relationship and
uses it her wisdom in our
decision-making and so you know you you
angry white feminists go ahead and send
me your stupid tweets because you're
idiots because this is not a feminist
issue this is a marriage issue and it's
the woosah fication of America where
some of you men need to stand up and be
men you're killing us in this culture
you're killing us seriously
and I'm not talking about you have to go
gut a deer or drive a four-wheel drive
that doesn't mean anything although I'm
not above doing either one of those
things that's not the point point is
have some anatomical attributes have a
backbone all right you know seriously
act like you are somebody men and women
and the two of you work together to
accomplish things I'm no more sexist
than fly to the moon half the operating
board in this organization of 500 people
are women my CMO is a lady two of my
EVPs are ladies and and they carry as
much of decision-making weight as much
wisdom around here sometimes more than
some of the leadership guys do in this
building my mom was a full time realtor
growing up and she was selling real
estate in 1968 before women sold real
estate now all the real estate is sold
by women just about but back in those
days we got hate mail put in our mailbox
because a woman dared to enter the
business world so I'm long away from
being a sexist that's not the point
but the point is men and women are
different and that's a good thing and if
you're married God put you together and
you need to both of you use your dadgum
brains and backbones when you're making
decisions so ladies don't call in here
and say my husband wouldn't let me
because I'm going to call you out on
being a wimp too but for goodness sakes
men don't call in here and be a boy
either my wife wouldn't let me worse
seriously I'm sorry but it's just awful
out there you guys there's this attack
on
masculinity that's just ridiculous I'm
sorry I'm not nurturing get over it you
know seriously somebody else can pick up
that paddle and run with it it's not me
I'll be compassionate and caring and
I'll serve you and I'll help you but I
may not be nurturing it may not be in
the way I'm wired oh well so here's the
thing both of you are making your
decisions together or you don't have a
healthy marriage either you're dealing
with a wuss or a test pilot from a broom
Factory or something's going on here but
you guys need to get this stuff
organized and start making your
decisions together because if I hear
that stuff I'm going to call you on it
man or woman that's the deal I'm going
to call you on it you've got to step up
and work together let me tell you the
correlating thing that I see more than
anything else you hear these families
come in here do these debt-free screams
and they paid off eighty thousand they
paid off one hundred eighty thousand
they paid off forty thousand they paid
off thirty eight thousand whatever they
paid off every time I ask them what's
the key to getting out of debt you know
what they say you hear them over and
over and over again if you listen this
show they say we're we're on a budget
and we were working to gather every time
you don't hear as couple stand in here
and say we paid off $80,000 and every
time I want to do something my wife
wouldn't let me you don't hear that and
you don't hear my husband told me what
to do and I just did whatever he said do
cuz I'm too stupid to use my own brain
somebody told me females weren't
supposed to have a brain you don't hear
that you don't hear that you hear two
solid people that joined arms and said
we're killing this together and they
kill it together and working together is
the key that's what's going on this is
huge you guys it's huge
and when we force families to do a
budget together
it forces communication and it forces
cooperation and did you listen to this
statistic all the the women's magazines
the read books and the women's day and
all this doing the surveys when ladies
are surveyed men listen to this one when
asked if they would like more come
in their marriage 97% say yes let me
help you with that that's all of them
and that's even if they called Sharon
Ramsey and aren't communication more
communication that's just a standard
deal when you start doing a budget
together your cooperating and your
communicating when men are asked what
they would like more of from their wives
it's only fifty seven percent but it's
still statistically significant say
cooperation you want cooperation and
communication in your marriage men and
women have a backbone
use your brain be mature adults devise a
plan and follow it children do what
feels good don't be four years old
emotionally have something noble that
you're aiming at like changing your
family tree getting our life back from
Sallie Mae and getting away from
Chrysler freakin credit have a plan here
lock arms together communicate cooperate
and do the written budget and don't call
in here and say my wife wouldn't let me
my husband wouldn't let me seriously
I'll call you out on it from now on
today on that's it we just put a new bar
right here on the Dave Ramsey show
that's it I was nice to both those guys
but it went through my head what that's
what went through my head when I heard
that both times I was trying you know I
don't want to embarrass a caller I'm not
beating callers up unless they just
demand to be embarrassed and then I do
but you know I'm not that I'm not that
talk-show host that my goal is to
destroy every caller but that's what
went through my head when I hear that
phrase my wife wouldn't let me
what really my husband wouldn't let me
what so what we have here is not a
financial problem we have a marriage
problem we have a relationship breakdown
there's a lack of respect both
directions
you know people listen ladies that are
of substance do not want a daddy they
want a husband men that are of substance
don't want a mommy they want a wife
if you're if you say stuff like my wife
only gives me so much money
well she your mother - you ought to be
working together my husband's got me on
allowance what are you 12 years old step
up here be adults both of you if you
want to call that sexist jump in the
Twitter Creek I'll blow you up on
Twitter if you mess with me on this
you're completely out of line if you do
but the wood suffocation of America it's
time it stopped you guys some of you men
man we need some men in this culture
this is the Dave Ramsey show